what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are officially starting the
Thanos war is really what this is I
don't know which title is better the
Thanos war or Thanos invades earth and
like crush it and light and like steals
a cosmic you like I have I have no idea
the Cosmic Cube saga but that's
basically what this is it's the Cosmic
Cube saga those of you guys where we've
talked about like Thanos this
publication history we've talked about
the idea that Thanos invaded earth wants
to steal the Cosmic Cube that's what
this is that's what this story basically
covers but before we get into this we
need to talk about Captain Marvel so
Captain Marvel or as I prefer to call
him Marvel was basically like Marvel
sticking it to DC that's really all it
was back in like a little back in 1940's
for the most part really like the late
late 1930s when Superman first appeared
in Action Comics Fawcett publications
the president went to Bill Parker and CC
back and said give me Superman without
Superman and the result is that they
made Captain Marvel and so for a while
he was wildly popular in fact he
actually outsold Superman he doubled
Superman's sales for quite some time
DC ultimately sued Fawcett publications
and FASTA had to take Captain Marvel off
the shelves well over the course of this
lawsuit because of the fact that DC
ultimately won and then got the rights
to the character and then basically put
him on the back burner for 20 years
during this 20-year period the copyright
lapsed and so Marvel immediately stole
it they basically said okay we're gonna
copyright the name Captain Marvel and
we're gonna create a superhero based on
that name that's why it is that when the
original Captain Marvel came back in DC
in the 1970s they had to rename him to
Shazam because they couldn't use the
name and so again that kind of goes into
the future of his character but really
the the Captain Marvel character er
Marvel was we're talking about here this
was Stan Lee and Gene Colan back in the
day he was introduced in Marvel
superheroes number 12 now we've talked
about this before Marvel superheroes was
one of those multitude of publications
that existed out there from comic book
publishers who would basically use it as
a testbed our fans interested in this
character and the result is that they
would kind of switch characters out so
you might have a series of these
anthology books or this kind of you know
singular stories that feature some
interesting superhero and you'll have
like three of them in a row and then you
know Marvel or DC or whoever will gauge
the sales of that and decide whether or
not people like it and if they do then
they'll give them their own solo series
and test that for a little while and if
it works they'll keep it going that's
what they did with Adam warlock
ultimately didn't succeed because the
warlock kind of dropped off on the time
issue number twelve came around but the
fact remains here and that when it came
to Marvel the way he was originally done
fans didn't really like
I mean when when Stanley Jack Kirby Gene
Colan were making this guy basically it
was this idea that he was just from a
race called decree and the curry of
course as we know are one of those
massive spacefaring empires that exists
out there in Marvel Comics they've been
around for quite some time and they had
ultimately sent a spy to earth to
monitor earth to see if it was a threat
what ended up happening is in classic
you know Stanley may a manner of
storytelling the hero side of things
came out and Marvel basically became a
good guy he was therefore arrested by
the Kree eventually made his escape but
fans didn't really care for too much and
so we're eventually white Thomas took
over the title and Marvel continued to
make all these different changes where
they basically took the character of
Rick Jones and they merged him with
Captain Marvel by using the negeb and
that were hit together ultimately it
wasn't really until jim Starlin took
over the publication that people found
it to be interesting and this is why I
say jim Starlin was so important and
that's kind of reasons why it kind of
sucks that Marvel pushed him out because
the Marvel cosmic landscape wouldn't be
where it is without Jim stone you know
Adam warlock and Gamora and you know
Drax a destroyer and you know a lot of
these cosmic escapades were designed for
the purpose by jim Starlin of really
transitioning these characters to a
cosmic landscape because understand Lee
and Jack Kirby and gene Cole and Captain
Marvel was an earth-based character but
earth was rapidly filling up with
superheroes and so you know readers kind
of had their pick of the litter and it
was very easy to kind of ignore certain
superheroes if they didn't resonate now
again the whole Captain Marvel Rick
Jones thing and that was in a lot of
ways a tribute to the old Captain Marvel
Billy Batson theme which is to say you
know back in the day when Captain Marvel
was made by DC you had Billy Batson who
as a kid he would shout the word Shazam
and then he would become Captain Marvel
this was designed to be the exact same
way with Rick Jones the difference here
is that Captain Marvel
you know Marvel was basically thrown
into the negative zone and then
eventually Rick Jones was contacted by
the supreme intelligence and the result
was that you know Rick Jones was led to
the negev ann's and when he struck him
together they would switch places and
they had like a three hour time limit
and so for the most part at the time
this story picks up Marvel is just kind
of there he's just kind of a superhero
who exists alongside the other
superheroes and Marvel and really he
wasn't the highest seller at this point
in time so model was trying to find a
way to rework him and so whenever we go
through and we do character explanations
and we say you know by the time this
writer came on board their attempt was
to rework this character and make it
more interesting this is exactly it you
guys are literally like in the over the
course of this video you're gonna be
seen that happen and
which is one of the reasons why it's
kind of cool but initially Captain
Marvel is just kind of beset upon by all
these different forces now the weight of
the whole Rick Jones
Captain Marvel scenario was brought to
us is that while they were only able to
switch bodies by hitting the nega bands
they could communicate with each other
and so the result was that you would
have Rick Jones who would chime in and
he would talk to captain you know
Captain Marvel about something and they
would even like communicate just based
on regular things if Marvel was trying
to understand the world around them
because remember he's not really of
Earth and so when he was trying to
understand things that were still
relatively new to him Rick Jones would
be the means by which he could achieve
that the problem with this is that he's
basically led to a building where he's
essentially arrested by a cop and it is
kind of intriguing because this cop is
just kind of like yeah man we saw you
commit this crime and you're under
arrest for murder and of course you end
up having LuAnn LuAnn Savannah who steps
in and says yes I saw him commit that
murder I mean obviously he's being
framed but LuAnn Savannah was the
attempt of Marvel to bring a love
interest in for the characters of Rick
Jones of Captain Marvel but the fact
that LuAnn effectively turns against
Marvel by saying yep you know I Salaam
could hit this crime but ultimately he's
taken to jail he's thrown in a Cell and
he's given handcuffs and that's really
about it but then suddenly he's met by
these characters like Ron in the accuser
jaan raghav the Incredible Hulk he's met
by all these villains who suddenly
seemingly start showing up out of
nowhere and start attacking him now in
truth this is jim Starlin giving us a
bit of a refresher course about the
various foes that captain Marvel's faced
over the years you know medicine and
different things like that you know
Zarek and so on and so forth these are
beings that were introduced by like Stan
Lee Gene Colan these kind of characters
that were designed to sort of be you
know arch enemies of Marvel they all
played a role in some form or fashion
that role was largely isolated to the
idea of Marvel having been part of the
create basically abandoning the Kree
Empire in favor of becoming a superhero
and the various you know accusations of
treason that came out of that that's
really where a lot of that stuff comes
from you know his first conflict with
name of the Submariner so on and so
forth but all this is basically revealed
to be an illusion of sorts but we also
end up finding out here is that this saw
this act is basically being perpetuated
by two beings one of them is named scrag
and the other one is super Skrull now
super school has a character that we've
never talked about well I took that back
if we have talked about super Skrull
it's really kind of making fun of them
and in truth that's the only way to talk
about him super Skrull was a scroll that
got the powers of the Fantastic Four
that's really all it was he really was
mostly an enemy of them but he's one of
those characters were when he pops up
it's just kind of like boat
though I mean there's so many other cool
enemies out there at the time back in
the 1960s it was cool because the
Fantastic Four were so huge they were so
popular but nowadays it's basically
copying the powers of a team that nobody
really cared about anymore I mean people
care about the Fantastic Four now
because they're not there but if people
really cared about the Fantastic Four
they would have been selling so bad in
the first place but the fact remains
here that it is interesting when it
comes to like how these different
characters are introduced and so on and
so forth not only that we're basically
told that you know super school
inscribed or answering to some you know
other being out there but they
essentially set all this stuff up they
were the ones who were disguised as the
cop they were the ones that basically
forced LuAnn or seemed to force the wind
to basically say yeah I saw you know
Captain Marvel commit this murder that
kind of a thing they were impersonating
the Incredible Hulk
they were impersonating all these people
which is why they came in sections they
didn't all come at one time is because
it was the Scrolls acting in accordance
to that whole idea now of course
released spill the beans and of course
they believe that Captain Marvel's
knocked out he's not he pops up battles
them and they end up just kind of having
to escape they essentially have to take
off and essentially teleport away now
this kind of asks the question what's
going on and why is this happening in
the first place and so what we end up
doing is we pick up with Marvel who
basically goes to meet LuAnn and what
new and Dodds is basically spill the
beans and this is when we start to get
into the cosmic side of things that
little first hibbott were it was marvel
fighting the scrolls you know and the
whole idea of LuAnn that was the way his
stories were all originally told and
they weren't that great but the whole
idea behind this is that LuAnn basically
says that it's somewhere along the line
she was basically taken to a facility or
at least it seems like she was taken to
a facility whereby she was given some
kind of an obedience disk more or less
and that while the thing doesn't
necessarily control everything she does
it does control certain words certain
key words but she also talks about the
character of Thanos now one thing to
bear in mind here is this is technically
the second appearance of Thanos we
already covered the first appearance
what he fought Iron Man you know when it
was basically a robot Thanos and not the
actual one
this is him effectively returning now
why it's all happening what kind of
flesh that out but the fact that she
says you know this is Stannis and he
rules Titan the the you know the moon
orbiting Saturn with an iron fist he's
essentially killed everybody that's
actually living there and instead it's
being occupied by an army that he's
formed what she basically says is he's
plotting and scheming to invade the
earth so it's kind of cool because of
course where she you know initially kind
of begins to attack Marvel and he's able
to subdue her to a degree but we end up
finding out is that she is being
controlled 100% it's just that it's
scratchy and super scroll putting on
this perception that she's not
controlled in her entire
now following this we pick up with super
scroll making his appearance and really
showing up to an attack Ben Grimm now
again because of the fact that super
scroll was originally an enemy of the
Fantastic Four it they're well aware of
who he is and of course Ben Grimm
immediately picks up on the fact that
this is super scroll and responds
accordingly because super scroll says
well you know if you really want to
battle meet me at you know for one for
West 44th Street now the other half of
this is that LuAnn says well this is
where she was taken when this disc was
thrown on ur so it's basically jim
Starlin kind of playing it fast and
loose with the idea of man Ben Grimm
might be taken possession of now one
thing to keep in mind is that while you
might be looking at this and just kind
of like okay so who cares it's Ben Grimm
back then that was huge Ben Grimm being
used by an enemy and just becoming like
this wrecking ball it was pretty
significant because back then Ben Grimm
was one of the only beings who could
actually go toe-to-toe with The
Incredible Hulk
he was that strong that's how Marvel
really kind of elevated its character
and made him pretty significant that in
the fact that he was one of the founding
members of the Fantastic Four so he was
already kind of itched in stone no pun
intended as one of the more founding and
significant members of Marvel Comics the
whole idea is that when he shows up in
this building his voice is immediately
taken away at the same time because of
the fact luan had said this is where she
was basically put through the process of
having a disk attached to her so she
would be controlled leads Captain Marvel
to this location and the whole idea is
to essentially serve as a distraction of
sorts that if Captain Marvel was able to
you know basically get away from the
accusations of murder that they can in
turn actually have him kill Ben Grimm
and the result is that he would
essentially be put on trial for that now
this is kind of weird because it's one
of those things where Marvel could but
maybe he couldn't I mean what Ben Grimm
like if he fights are the absolute peak
and he just keeps going and going then
sure he'd probably be able to topple
Marvel but the way the jim Starlin plays
this off is that Marvel would be able to
topple Ben Grimm and that's the initial
you know kind of indication this is
sympton essentially Marvel just kind of
overpowers Ben Grimm by shocking him
with electricity and what this does is
it basically takes that voice you know
paralyzer more or less and it eliminates
it in its entirety and so what ends up
happening here is Ben Grimm starts
talking to Marvel and effectively they
learn they've both been tricked here now
the other half is remember you still got
fan OHS watching all this unfold and a
cloaked figures kind of skulking around
in the background watching everything
take place so it is kind of cool because
ultimately we end up having Ben Grimm
and Captain Marvel show up on the
doorstep of where Thanos is operating
out of and when they break in not only
are they met with Thanos they're also
met with mistress death now this is her
first appearance at Marvel comic
and it's very very important that we
talk about this in Marvel Comics when it
comes to the idea of death and dying
there was no real definitive standard
outside of like hella from the from the
Thor Comics remember it wasn't until
1975 when when Chris Claremont took over
the x-men that things like the Phoenix
were introduced and we got places like
the white hot room and these various
indications of what the afterlife is
like for people who died before this
story right here before the introduction
of mistress death in the role she plays
essentially it was this idea that
whenever people died those who died in
battle went to Valhalla those who didn't
die in battle they went to the realm of
hella now going to the realm of hella
didn't mean you went to like fire and
brimstone and health that was just the
afterlife for anybody who didn't die in
battle in honor of Asgard that was
essentially the only place she went to
with this story and the introduction of
mistress death what Marvel started doing
especially under the writing of jim
Starlin is they started shifting things
up and so what they did is they sort of
split the difference because the the
question fans would have had is okay if
up until this point we have hella who's
the representation of death and Marvel
Comics because there's nobody else that
stands in for her character then how do
we justify the existence of mistress
death and are the two related to each
other is you know hella just like a
different aspect of mistress death or
something like that
Marvel split the difference and what
they began doing is they basically said
okay those individuals who did die in
honorable battle and believe in Asgard
they go to Valhalla everybody else goes
to the realm of mistress death and
that's it so the average person living
on the street that's like a Baptist
Christian they go to the realm of
mistress death or something along those
lines and then we started getting into
the introduction of characters like
Mephisto where Mephisto his realm is for
those individuals who he tricks and
whose souls he steals that's basically
where that whole thing comes from and
there's all cut all other kinds of after
lives that were introduced as well like
there is an actual hell there is an
actual heaven there's all these
different things that kind of spun out
of the introduction and mistress death
but that's why she's so important
because it opened the door that there's
more to where people can go when they
die than just hella and the whole idea
of Asgard and things like that now this
also set in motion the relationship
between mistress death and Thanos but
one thing to keep in mind here is that
this is the actual Thanos it's not a
robot Thanos that we saw an Iron Man
number 55 and the whole idea behind this
is that this version of Thanos is much
much stronger than his robot version of
course he immediately overpowers Ben
Grimm and again 1960s comics this is Jim
Stalin's way of saying danos has nobody
to trifle with with the character of
Marvel he immediately forces Marvel
and Rick Jones to switch places which
had never happened before but with
regards to the defeat of Marvel and you
know with Rick Jones kind of being you
know with him being forced to switch and
Rick Jones being uh I guess the the
prominent character Thanos basically
grabs them and whisks you know whis off
for the two of them he does kind of
absconds with with with Rick Jones now
what we end up finding out here is the
motivation behind Thanos for doing this
is to take the mind of Rick Jones hook
it up to the computer
Isak which is the computer system that
kind of governs everything that goes on
with regards to the planet Titan and
find some secret that Rick Jones harbors
and what we get is this kind of
play-by-play of the lives of the
characters to a degree the immediate
past and how their powers work so again
this is jim Starlin kind of hitting at
those things kind of giving out readers
a refresher course on the character of
marvel what we end up finding out is
that the secret that Thanos is hunting
for is the Cosmic Cube that for whatever
reason Rick Jones knows of its location
and the location is on earth now this is
not the first appearance of the Cosmic
Cube the first appearance of the cosmic
you came in tales of suspense number 79
uh don't quote me on that but it was
basically a concept introduced by Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby and it fit very well
when it came to their line of
storytelling's because you know the
Cosmic Cube is basically a wishing box
that's really all it is when a person is
in possession of the Cosmic Cube they
can make anything a reality even if it
defies all forms of logic and reason and
different things like that now one of
the things that people usually try to do
is they try to provide a hierarchy of
powerful powerful artifacts the heart of
the universe versus the Infinity
Gauntlet versus the Cosmic Cube and how
do these ranks in a rank in accordance
with one another well in truth there is
a hierarchy but there's not a hierarchy
you're talking about a power that's so
extreme that they can all basically do
the same thing the difference is how
they're used
that's the differing factor with regards
to what these things can do for example
the heart of the universe blinked out
the entirety of the multiverse and
destroyed all the cosmic entities say
for the one above all that was the power
of the heart of the universe but that as
a story is out of continuity and as far
as Marvel's concerned it never really
even happened but when it comes to the
cosmic key when it comes to the Infinity
Gauntlet they can basically do the same
thing the Infinity Gauntlet a lot more
popular because of the Infinity Gauntlet
story and the Infinity stones and the
fact that they've stood the test for so
long in terms of readership and how
they're used and who's acquired them and
different things like that but you could
take the Cosmic Cube
and you could replace the Infinity
Gauntlet with the cube and it all still
works but originally the cube was
introduced at
an artifact belonging to a group called
advanced idea mechanics and that
introduced the notion that the cosmic
you basically is or at least a cube
shape itself is a storage space for the
energy of the beyonders now the idea of
it being energy of the yonder's that
wouldn't be really introduced until God
I want to say fantastic for 214 or 215
or something like that
it was the unofficial sequel to secret
Wars 1 & 2 and it was the whole idea
that like the D honors these beings that
exist outside the multiverse and that
their energy can be accessed using a
cosmic cube and then if you have
something to contain that energy then
it'll give you godly powers you can do
anything that you want to control all of
reality that's kind of how all that
stuff sort of fell into an explanation
but at the outset what it was originally
brought in it was just a wishing box and
so the whole idea is that somewhere on
earth it resides and Thanos is looking
to acquire it the other half of this is
that we're also met with Rick Jones
who's kind of me under all this rubble
and all this stuff and of course he's
met by the arrival of eros and mentor
now with the character of eros it was
this idea that he's the brother of
Thanos and the whole motivation behind
this is they are like the two that
opposed Thanos as best they can but
Thanos has killed every other member of
the race so there's really nobody else
there and how of course Mentos are not
Mentos Mentos Mentos the fresh making
father of Thanos mentor was the one
responsible for partitioning Kronos to
create Drax a destroyer
who's the guy that's basically out there
to take out Thanos as often as he can
right now he's in hiding and we'll find
out where he is here in a little while
but when it comes to ero Sandman swore
they're just like the last vestiges of
the rebellion against Thanos is really
all it is
the idea behind this is that they
basically kind of provide this history
for the character of Thanos and really
they care the the the whole landscape of
Titan itself now this is really designed
for the purpose of a refresher for those
individuals who don't really know any of
the history of Thanos we've covered him
enough I mean we've done the origin of
Thanos we've done Thanos explained
you're welcome to go check those out if
you want to know the whole thing it'll
be on the Marvel cosmic playlist so
you'll see all that all that cosmic
stuff because this is what all that goes
into this is all leading up to Infinity
Ward but what is up happening here is we
end up having Rick Jones basically
bringing back bringing back Captain
Marvel just because of the fact that
he's conscious now he can return his
character in a photo effectively kind of
go forward as a superhero at this point
we transition over to Thanos and to to
mistress death who have arrived in all
places Louisiana
apparently the Cosmic Cube resides in
Louisiana not really sure why I guess
for some reason is just kind of you know
residing in the bayou
I don't know somebody down in Louisiana
got it and they've just kind of been
doing crazy stuff ever since I have no
idea but LuAnn has also been selling a
mission by Rick Jones to contact the
Avengers and so that's why this is
important because this grabs the
Avengers team and brings him into the
story now of course LuAnn showing up
here with the Avengers card of Rick
Jones which kind of a fun fact back in
the sixties you had to have a card in
order to get into Avengers mansion
otherwise they wouldn't let you in it
was kind of funny but with a win showing
up here using Rick Jones card and the
fact that the end the Avengers know who
luan is and of course let her in and
then luan basically you know promptly
passes out as a result of her whole you
know emotionally and physically taxing
ordeal but picking up with mentor
alongside eros as well as you know
Marvel we basically have them like
invade and attack the forces of phantoms
and they're taken out pretty quickly I
mean this isn't designed to be a great
big huge long drawn-out conflict
immunise to a degree in terms of the
fight with super Skrull but all that's
just because he's so powerful but the
other important thing to draw from this
is that Marvel is kind of relishing in
the fires of combat like he's really
really getting into it and he's getting
overly excited into the whole battle and
it's designed to feed on the notion that
Marvel loves conflict and that's gonna
be a very important thing the reason why
is because once he arrives at Avengers
mansion and is basically told by you
know Black Panther hey look like LuAnn
showed up here and LuAnn struggling and
she's probably gonna die you know he
immediately freaks out switches back to
his form of Rick Jones and then while
he's in this sort of a negative zone
plane he suddenly witnesses the
character of Eon now Eon this is his
first appearance and we'll actually talk
about him here in a minute but he's one
of the cosmic entities that exists out
there and he's actually responsible for
the really for the characters like
quasar kind of being like the protectors
of the universe different things like
that but we'll talk more about that here
in a second the whole idea behind this
is that while Rick Jones is telling the
story and it transforms back into Marvel
and Marvel basically tells The Avengers
about how Thanos is trying to capture
the the Cosmic Cube some alarm bells
start going off with regards to an
intruder of course Black Panthers the
first to respond like Panthers taken out
we end up having vision who responds and
he's taken out you know Marvel is
telling them about these obedience discs
and different things like that and then
ultimately we end up with the arrival of
controller now controller was a person
who is basically invading the Avengers
mansion and crushing each and every one
of the Avengers but you know when it
came to the character of of basil
sandhurst he's a weird scenario so basil
Sandhurst he originally appeared back in
uh and he was originally an Ironman
villain and the whole idea behind this
was at Basel Sandhurst was basically a
guy who lived his life as a kid always
being sick and so he was always
bedridden for the most part eventually
he went on to basically become a
scientist he developed an exoskeleton
and what this suit did is it allowed him
to essentially absorb the mental
energies of other people into himself
and then grant himself some measure of
telepathy now the difference here is
that by the time this story came around
a multitude of schemes and campaigns had
gone on he conquered entire town he
basically enslaved his brother different
things like that but his powers have
effectively been augmented by Thanos and
what this means is that these small
little disks that are being attached to
people those were created by controller
and it's first a nose to essentially
start attaching them to like
high-ranking military officials things
like that so none of them will question
Thanos and we'll all be obedient and
controllable by Thanos by virtue of
controller and controller does this just
because of the fact that Thanos promises
him different things and so on and so
forth so it's a classic henchman you
know archetype that goes on here but the
whole idea is that controller is wildly
capable and extremely dangerous
especially with that whole exoskeleton
so he's pretty formidable in his own
right with his enhanced abilities
different things like that but for the
character of Thanos we jump back to him
in Louisiana and basically deal with
with Drax the destroyer showing back up
and I remember Drax the destroyer serves
a purpose of looking and do nothing more
than destroy Thanos that's his purpose
that's why he was created and the cool
thing about this is that Thanos uses
something called the time mind sync warp
which I've never seen use outside of
this story and as far as I'm aware jim
Starlin was exceedingly well known for
that he was really really good for
grabbing a concept and throwing him into
comics and that it's never seen or heard
from again but the whole timeline sync
warp is designed to essentially dominate
the minds of other people but this is
very important and the reason why this
matters is because this demonstrates the
fact that Thanos is well versed in the
idea of manipulating the minds of others
as well as occupying a space that's
designed to essentially demonstrate the
effects of reality warping this is one
of the reasons why when Thanos gets the
reality stone he's able to control it
and he's not immediately driven insane
by it because his mind can already
handle the effects of extreme reality
warping and so in this instance it's
designed to effectively break the mind
of Drax a destroyer but Drax the
destroyer is driven by the lone singular
purpose of killing Thanos and so the
result of this is that even though he's
kind of pushed to the brink even though
he survives the experience and he's
knocked unconscious it does allow
a knows to access the Cosmic Cube and to
effectively take off with it so what
this does is this segues back into
controller and and Captain Marvel and
there's not really a whole lot going on
there I mean controller basically
overpowers Marvel and he grabs two
stories of the Avengers building and
just throws it on him causing a massive
collapse of the building grabs LuAnn and
it takes off and that's really about it
but what it does is it leaves Rick Jones
under all this rubble under the
possibility of being crushed to death
but where he goes and strikes the nega
bands in an attempt to bring Marvel back
it doesn't work and the reason why this
doesn't work is because Marvel has been
brought before Eon now Eon is well I
guess we can if we can call him a child
uh he on is like the offspring of
eternity and that's where Marvel gets a
little crazy when it comes with a hold a
whole idea of entities Eon is one of
these beings that was created for the
purpose of monitoring time on earth and
he's been around for quite a while and
he's been around for ever and ever and
ever and ever but the whole idea was
that Eon is kind of a response to the
being Chronos who had basically come
along and said okay so like in a few
billion years like three billion years
dan else is going to rise to power and
he's gonna try to conquer the universe
and so we need to have a means to
prepare for that and so what ended up
happening here is that over the course
of these billions of years the cosmic
entities just waited now it would seem
like that would be like like kind of
ridiculous like why don't they just make
a person to wait until then well because
when you're a cosmic entity the passage
of time doesn't pass like it normally
does you know cosmic entities don't see
time that way humans do humans analyze
time based on you know the Earth's
revolution around the Sun and the number
of times that Earth spins on its axis
when you're a cosmic entity time is for
the most part irrelevant to you because
the universe will end you will die and
then you'll be reborn and then that's it
it's just kind of a death and rebirth
and so because of that what would seem
like three billion years for us would be
like the blink of an eye for cosmic
entities it wouldn't really be relevant
to them you know and so as a result
essentially what they've been doing is
waiting on the character of Marvel now
in terms of publication like on the
publication side stepping out of the
comic-book landscape this is jim Starlin
reworking the character of marvel is Jim
stone sitting down and saying okay Stan
Lee Jack Kirby Gene Colan Roy Thomas
they made him an earth-based superhero
and fans didn't like it so what have we
make of a cosmic superhero what if we
have him go to the Stars and he explores
space and all those different things
like that let's just see what happens
and let's see how fans respond to that
it's basically the idea that Eon appears
before Marvel and says what we need is a
champion we don't need
warrior we don't need a person who's
obsessed with conflict and that's the
whole point that takes place here Eon
essentially looks at the life of Marvel
and says you have been forged in the
fires of combat and that's all you've
known is war in conflict so long as you
get to fight you don't really care what
else goes on but that's not what the
universe needs the universe needs a
protector not necessarily a person that
can defeat every single threat in
existence but a person who knows which
people to pull in case there is a
massive conflict a leader for the cosmos
of sorts now this is very important this
is a very significant thing because
Marvel would basically kick the bucket
and die in 1984 with the death of
Captain Marvel what this did is it
allowed for jim Starlin to bring back
the character of adam warlock and have a
have Adam warlock take the place of
Marvel in the wall of Infinity Gauntlet
but the fact remains here what Marvel is
basically experiencing in this scenario
is one the character of uma this woman
that he was in love with who ultimately
ended up dying he's given this
perception of hey look your battle with
Yan rod the whole psyche nine Neutron
all those things that was all in a
desire to bring this woman back to life
which I as Yan can do and he basically
resurrects her but she's soulless she
likes the one thing that makes all
sentient beings the way they are she
locks his soul she doesn't have the
ability to like think for herself she's
just kind of a mindless shell as out
there and he on essentially says this is
what you would have gotten had you
resurrected her from the dead this is
what you would have had because she's
gone her soul is off in the afterlife
and you can't get that back now this is
jim Starlin kind of hinting at the idea
that mistress death is the gatekeeper
that when a person dies you can't just
bring them you can't just resurrect them
in a traditional sense it's essentially
Jim so insane mistress death is the
gatekeeper and she's holding all the
keys when a person dies their spirit
their soul goes to her realm and they
can only leave if she allows them to BEC
can happen you know where she's like
okay fine you can have your soul you can
go back and you can go back to your
regular body sometimes she'll even send
a person out of the realm of death and
then ban them from ever coming back it
was kind of crazy when it when it came
to that whole thing but the fact remains
here what he's basically experiencing is
something called cosmic awareness as
basically what he's being given here
he's being given this idea that you know
where his physical form changes he gets
blonde hair he gets a new uniform he's
basically being given cosmic awareness
there's nothing in the universe that
goes on that he doesn't know about he's
effectively aware of everything he's
aware of all life that's tingling all
across the universe now in truth
Marvel's not the first person to ever
achieve that and he won't be
last when it comes to to publication
history but how people deal with that is
really contingent on the writer a lot of
writers they'll depict it in a way where
a person's you know given cosmic
awareness and they start to go insane
because it's a massive influx of all
this energy coming in all at once it's
not just people talking
it's the alignment of the planets it's
the rotation of the planets as black
holes it's stars traveling asteroids and
comets just racing across the space
waist it's this massive influx of energy
that all comes in at once now jim
Starlin plays it fast and loose and he's
just like yep he's got cosmic awareness
now cool story bro but like most writers
are just kind of like they go absolutely
insane they lose their mind it takes
somebody of extreme power to bring them
back down and have them regain their you
know regain their sanity and kind of go
forward that's usually how that plays
out I mean if this story had been told
in like 2002 he would have gone nuts and
if probably would've taken someone like
Xavier or something like that to bring
him back down he would have attacked all
the Avengers or something along those
lines it would have been a lot different
but because of the fact that this story
is told at a time when it was more about
the fantasy of superheroes as opposed to
the grounded nature of heroes in
relation to how they would exist in the
real world
he just gets cosmic awareness he's like
awesome and he goes forward is like the
one guy that has the ability to unify
our superheroes in an effort to stop
Thanos but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb cork you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]